I have unique theory about where this all
fits into the Insidious timeline, stick around
to the end of this video where I'll discuss
that.
In this first shot there is a woman standing
out in the woods, but upon closer inspection,
it may not actually be a woman, but maybe
an owl or something?
It looks like there could also be someone
looking out the window.
There have been a lot of presences that have
made themselves known by appearing in the
window in the first three films, so my guess
is we'll see that come back.
In fact, it's like 99% confirmed later in
the trailer.
I personally hope we get to this guy again
at some point, cause he was one of my favorite
spooks from the original.
This is an Arri Kit, a set of lights that
we use in the film industry which come in
an easily transported container like this.
I'm not saying that this character is going
to be a filmmaker or anything.
Sometimes we just use equipment as props and
set decoration.
There are a lot of literal keys in this trailer,
one of the big questions is going to be what
does it all mean?
This creature seems to put this key into the
girl's vocal chords, I think that's the most
mature way I can describe that, and looks
to turn the key and lock away her voice.
Let's watch the clip again.
It's also more or less confirmed in the international
trailer, where she goes silent and the creature
does this.
I'll come back to the significance of that
in a moment.
But, another thing I noticed is that this
creature seems to be in our world, because
while the lighting is a bit reminiscent of
the The Further, that realm always has this
low-lying ground fog.
This scene does not.
The setting of this film looks like the southwest
USA, and in the international trailer, it's
mentioned that the film takes place in Five
Keys, New Mexico.
This is not a real town, so anything I deduct
about the setting in this video is intentionally
done that way by the filmmakers.
For example, the director chose to make this
welcome sign look like a tombstone.
He also chose to make the town's tagline "We'll
unlock your Heart."
If this creature can lock people's vocal chords,
it stands to reason that it can also lock
away other parts of the body as well.
In a metaphorical sense, there are maybe four
things that make up who a person really is;
we've seen each one manifested by characters
in The Wizard of Oz, for example.
You have their heart, which represents their
desires; their voice, which represents essentially
communication and friendship, their mind,
which obviously represents their thoughts;
and... how do I put this without getting demonetized...
Kahunas, which indicate courage.
There are other ways you can break these basic
human traits down, but you get the idea.
Now, in the Insidious movies, in The Further
we tend to see a bunch of human spirits and
this one demon who looks like Darth Maul.
From what I can gather, this keymaster creature
is another demon from that world.
While Darth Maul's main objective was to take
over a human vessel, I think this new creature
operates a bit differently.
When a character Astral Projects, they're
putting themselves out there; outside of their
human body, and what they are projecting is
more or less the essence of who they are,
their mind, their heart, their voice or otherwise.
I think this creature preys on people by either
locking specific traits outside of their body
or possibly locking them in and effectively
limiting their astral abilities.
As you can imagine, either of these could
be used to terrify someone, especially if
you have to confront or defeat this keymaster
creature in order to unlock yourself.
There's even more importance to the keys than
that though.
In Insidious, the Red-Faced Demon has his
own domain in The Further, with the shackles,
the record player, and this claw sharpening
device.
I think this new demon's domain is going to
be in this prison; which would make sense
for him since prisons are filled with locks
and he's literally made of keys.
Speaking of the lair's of these demons, I
think they may be the only clue to figuring
out why this clown thing is in the trailer.
This is admittedly pretty weak, but the only
connection I can make is to the clown dolls
we see in the Red-Face demon's lair.
In the international trailer, we get a peek
at this girl's sketches, and they are very
similar to the drawings done by Dalton in
Insidious.
You'll also notice that her mouth is stitched
shut, which adds more support my idea of her
voice being locked by that creature.
Now I'm gonna get into the timeline stuff,
so buckle in because it gets a bit confusing.
Let me first review the timeline of events
so far so we're all on the same page.
The earliest point we've seen so far is Elise
as a younger adult in Chapter 2, when she
helps Josh Lambert forget about his astral
abilities as a child.
This is also the period to which the adult
versions of these characters travel back to
see the origins of The Black Bride, as he's
abused by his mother, the woman in white.
Chronologically, the next time we see Elise
is after her retirement in Chapter 3.
She comes out of retirement to help Quinn
Brenner eradicate The Man Who Can't Breathe
and reconnect with her late mother.
By this time, The Black Bride is grown up
and Elise has to fight it off.
This is also where she meets Specs and Tucker.
A few years later, the events of the original
movie unfold.
Elise helps the Lambert family bring back
their son Dalton from the Further, and Josh
Lambert has to relearn how to astral project
in order to do so.
At the end, The Black Bride possesses Josh's
body and kills Elise.
That leads us to the present portion of Chapter
2, where Elise's spirit in The Further drives
out the Black Bride from Josh's body just
before he kills his family.
So where does this fourth installment take
place?
Let's look at the trailer again.
Elise seems to be telling the story as a flashback.
"These hauntings can be terrifying things.
I should know.
I've faced many evils in my lifetime."
We are then shown clips from each of the three
Insidious movies.
She also says, 'this was different though.'
Key word: was.
So we know she's telling a story from the
past and the story is being told from some
time after this scene in Chapter 2.
Probably before the final cliffhanger scene
though.
The story she's telling takes place after
Chapter 3, we know that because she is already
working with Specs and Tucker, but before
Insidious, because she's not dead.
In this story, we hear her say the following.
"The haunted house... is my family's house."
I think we're actually going to see flashbacks
within the flashback that frames the movie,
and get a look in on Elise's childhood and
young adult years as a result.
Notice how this girl and Elise are never in
the same shot?
Maybe it's because they're the same person.
It makes sense because they both astral project.
"I can see things too."
Here's the best piece of evidence though.
The girl examines this jacket in the house.
If you pause at just the right moment, the
name tag shows a first name ending in O, last
name Rainier, which is also Elise's last name.
Her husband is mentioned in Chapter 3 and
his name is Jack, which if you weren't aware,
does not end in the letter O. My theory is
that the jacket belongs to Elise's father,
who also seems to be Asst.
Warden at the prison, the lurking place of
the keymaster creature.
Maybe the keymaster is connected somehow to
Elise's relationship with her father.
Maybe they're even the same person.
I think the way that the international trailer
is edited also suggests that this girl and
Elise are one and the same.
Older Elise is attacked and younger Elise
goes flying.
It's treated as one sequence.
She also looks similar enough to the younger
version of Elise from Chapter 2.
In addition to seeing Elise as a young adult,
we'll also see her as a child.
Take a closer look at how this little girl
responds to the name Elise.
"Elise."
So, if everything I predicted is true, then
maybe this character right here is a younger
version of The Bride In Black.
He see him as a child in Chapter 2 being scolded
for using a male name, Parker, and we know
he has the elder female alter ego who killed
15 people.
We also know that he's followed her for a
very long time.
This wallpaper in the trailer for the new
movie matches the wallpaper in Parker's room,
and there may or may not be a connection between
the butterflies on Elise's shirt and those
on the wall in Parker's room.
There may be other references as well, so
let me know what you saw in the comments.
If you're excited for this movie, let me know
by leaving this video a like.
And if you're a fan of horror, I mean I'm
assuming you are if you're here at this point,
you're gonna want to subscribe to this channel,
CZsWorld, for new horrors every week.
Later today I'll be on the air, with Lady
White Rabbit and Mortis Media for a new episode
of our live show, The Deadstream, so join
us for that at 2PM pacific, 5PM eastern.
That's 10PM GMT.
All you have to do is ring the deathbell for
notifications, and I'll see you this afternoon.
Assuming we both survive.